We need new heroes one suited for the times we're
in courageous righteous the best in all of us
the danger with superheroes they become
icons wars are fought movements are formed
people need something to get behind
and we're going to do it our own way
not until symbols are dead and replaced you okay
she will escalate and will not stop
the onlypower i have is that i believe we can do better
In the show we're gonna get a chance to
explore sam and bucky in ways we haven't seen
before let's get to work we have fun with each
other and i think it comes across on the screen
so what's our plan so no plan you get a kick
out of seeing them coexist and work together
for the first time what's going on in that
cyborg brain of yours you don't want to know
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
falcon and winter soldier episode 2 trailer video
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs and a whole
bunch of new characters that we didn't see during
episode 1 so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel i'm doing videos for
all the episodes be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's a whole bunch of new marvel
disney plus stuff happening this year loki is
actually going to be the next series after this
but this trailer gives us way more baron zemo he
wasn't really featured during episode one because
they were mostly reintroducing falcon and winter
soldier after the events of avengers end game
and just teasing the flag smashers group a little
kind of explaining what's going on in the world
a few months after avengers end game now that all
the blip people have come back and they've kind
of gotten used to being back so everyone's back to
their old ways so to speak and that's sort of the
problem that they're dealing with with the flag
smashers we want to go back to the way things were
before the blip i actually laughed a little when
they said that like wait a minute they want to go
back to that post-apocalyptic environment baron's
emo must be gaslighting the hell out of them to
make them think that that was better we get a much
longer version of baron zemo's speech about why he
thinks superhero should not exist the danger of
superheroes it's sort of a twist on the avengers
age of ultron captain america civil war speech
like the vision speech where he talks about our
very existence invites challenge challenge incites
conflict and then things escalate from there
but they juxtapose baron's emo's speech with
falcon and winter soldiers speeches about why
symbols superheroes are important and the flag
smashers speech aaron kellyman's speech about
replacing old symbols with new ones and just to
be clear they did confirm that her character is
a gender-bent version of the flag smasher
character from the comics but they're also
using the flag smasher name is the name of their
group so it's sort of like a spartacus situation
like i am spartacus no i am spartacus they're
using it as both her name and the name of the
group at the same time but i don't think that
anybody on the tv show itself within the context
of the story is going to call her flag smasher
they're just going to call her kari her name or
the crazy girl that's running around causing all
this havoc but some of this footage actually makes
it seem like baron zemo might share some scenes
with the flag smashers like he's in a very similar
looking church here building is the flag smashers
so he might be speaking to them and they look like
they're all just kind of huddled together like
something terrible has happened and they're trying
to deal with it so early theory because it's baron
zemo we're talking about he might be trying to
gaslight them or manipulate them in some way into
creating all this chaos around the world allowing
him to fulfill his ultimate goal of getting
rid of superheroes that's a very general plan
that's pretty basic so i'm assuming we'll get the
full villain monologue eventually the same way he
went full villain monologue during captain america
civil war daniel bruhl explained what's different
about zemo after avengers end game like what's
changed since the events of captain america civil
war when they locked him up in prison so at the
end of captain america civil war he chilled out
just a little bit but originally his whole thing
was just trying to get revenge on the avengers
revenger style blaming them for the death of his
family in sokovia during the events of avengers
age of ultron he blamed them for creating
that situation in the first place even though
technically ultron was the villain he actually
said that they were responsible the avengers
were responsible through their very nature their
existence leading to the rise of ultron in iron
man directly being responsible for the creation
of ultron sharing a little bit more of the blame
but that leading to the battle that destroyed
sokovia even though they did manage to save
most of the city minus a quicksilver or two
they kind of addressed this during Wandavision
too with the scarlet witch flashback scenes to
her childhood showing you the stark tech bomb
that killed their parents before she used her hex
magic to create a probability spell stopping the
bomb from exploding before it could also kill her
in quicksilver little baby scarlet witch thrown
spells all over the place like it's her job then
they joined baron von strucker's hydra program
with the infinity stone the mine stone as a way
to fight back so it's kind of the same basic idea
with baron zemo and the flag smashers his plan for
getting revenge was just a little more insidious
in the case of captain america civil war break
the avengers up destroy the team but with a twist
and he was kind of successful the way they left
him in captain america civil war but according to
daniel bruhl he just festered in prison until
the events of avengers infinity war he also
revealed that zemo was snapped then blipped back
and that sort of reignited his previous sentiment
about the avengers and superheroes in general
luxemo blames them for the events of the snap
like vision speech i said earlier our very
existence invites challenge from villains villains
like thanos the funny thing about that though zemo
wants to get rid of the avengers you're the reason
this happened thanos would have snapped half the
universe even if the avengers never existed but
now after avengers end game he's like i was right
the first time but i didn't take things far enough
and because he is a villain is much more insidious
than your traditional marvel villains like thanos
it seems like he's trying to work from the shadows
through the flag smashers but the flag smashers
themselves aren't an inherently evil group the way
they kind of explain it during episode one is that
it's turned into this big message board thing this
big grassroots movement and they're all kind of
being gaslit by zemo even though aaron kellyman's
character and some of these others seem like they
have the super soldier serum and they're the real
flag smashers they're kind of turning it into a
big grassroots online movement but they themselves
don't start out being evil characters they're just
on the down and out after avengers end game and
things are just really bad for them and zemo
takes advantage of that the same way that scarlet
witch isn't necessarily an evil character more of
an anti-hero but both agatha harkness and tyler
hayward spent that whole series trying to gaslight
her in her moment of weakness so that they could
take something from her take advantage of her
agatha harkness wanted to take her chaos magic
her power outright like give me all of your power
and tyler hayward kind of wanted her chaos magic
power too but for a slightly different reason
just to power up the version of white vision so
early theory about aaron kellyman's flag smasher
character after the falcon and winter soldier
series is over they keep her around for future
thunderbolts or young avengers projects like she
comes back in the future disney plus series or
marvel movies and they just give her a new comic
book name or a new costume like she's not an evil
character she's kind of an anti-hero here but why
would you power someone up so much and try to make
the audience sympathize with their cause over the
course of the series then throw them in prison not
to bring them back again like you have to imagine
thunderbolt ross taking advantage of that look you
have a particular set of skills you have a measure
of superpowers like a little bit of superpowers
so we'll cut some time off your sentence because
you committed so many crimes while you were part
of the flag smashers if you join my special team
we get way more footage of falcon training at his
home in louisiana winter soldiers showing up
to help train him with the shield and prep for
their missions to investigate the flag smashers
the footage of the highway fight scene with
them hijacking the shipment might be from later
episodes i don't know if this happens in episode 2
so soon in the series a lot of this footage
could be from later episodes but i like that
winter soldier twist here where it seems like he's
jumping onto the back of this truck thinking that
he's rescuing her like hey you okay and she just
smiles and kicks him right out the back baron
zemo sounds like he's talking to falcon and winter
soldier in this later voice over when he's telling
them she's going to keep escalating things like it
won't stop until she completes her goal and it's
not totally clear what they plan to do like what
baron zemo wants them to do but it sounds like
some global terror threat then the falcon kind of
explains his superpower like i don't actually have
super powers my superpower is the belief that we
can do better i know a lot of people are wondering
if they are turning him into a version of captain
america the next version of captain america
will they also give him a version of the super
soldier serum like winter soldier has like the
flag smashers seem like they have i don't know if
they have any plans to upgrade him in that way i
do think he's going to get a new costume and some
new gear but i actually don't think that he needs
the super soldier serum like the whole concept
of his character is that he's the regular guy
trying to hold his own amongst traditionally super
powered people on the avengers hawkeye and black
widow are other really good examples of that like
just regular people with particular sets of skills
and when you think about it falcon is kind of
doing the same thing that iron man is doing on the
avengers like iron man does not have superpowers
like thor he uses his technology to give him an
edge in battle falcon also uses tech they kind of
confirmed during episode 1 that the wingsuit and
the drone his red wing drone are stark tech and
speaking of iron man upgrading captain america's
technology they kind of did that back during age
of ultron like you remember captain america had
the special magnets on the back of the shield
instead of just using the traditional harness
but we also get a ton of new scenes of winter
soldier meeting falcon's family just funny
moments his sister and her kids they did have a
joke previously about him not flirting with his
sister like don't you dare flirt with my sister
we talk about how this series is kind of like
marvel's lethal weapon rigs and murtaugh that's
actually a lethal weapon joke except during lethal
weapon it was his daughter that he was flirting
with we haven't seen them go to madrapur yet that
footage could also be from later in the series
since they haven't even had their big team-up
training montage yet but the episodes are so much
longer than the Wandavision episodes and there are
fewer episodes overall so they are blowing through
the plot way faster the whole thing with us agent
captain america john walker here is that the
government probably learns about the flag smashers
as well or the flag smashers do something to steal
something from the united states military and they
roll in new captain america as the wrecking crew
and he's probably just going to try and outright
kill all their group including aaron kellyman's
character and it seems like falcon and winter
soldier are trying to reason with them in order to
stop things from escalating further like the whole
idea they don't want to turn aaron kellyman's
character into a new martyr and make the
flagsmasher movement escalate because it is this
big online movement if you don't recognize them
people are making all these jokes about how he
looks like the character from up like the old man
in a captain america costume just because of the
way his face looks underneath that mask it's wyatt
russell who's playing the character playing the
john walker us agent character he's kurt russell's
son in real life ego the living planet so funny
marvel connection there they will get into his
backstory in the next few episodes and how he came
to be the next captain america as they continue to
explain the weapons plus program in greater detail
but if you spotted any of the big easter eggs
during the trailer that i didn't talk about during
the video or any big questions you have about
the series so far just write them below in the
comments in my full falcon winter soldier episode
2 video we'll post next friday just like normal
i've got a couple other justice league snyder
cut videos that i'm going to be posting this
weekend and next week too just because it's so
big there's so much stuff to talk about there too
but everyone click here for my full falcon winter
soldier episode one video and click here for my
full justice league snyder cut ending and end
credit scene video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!